à après des mois d'attentes de
confinement de mesures sanitaires en
tout genre on peut apprécier un petit
cocktail en terrasse après avoir fait du
shopping puis enchaîner sur un 6 mai ou
un théâtre
bon on peut pas encore envisager de
finir la soirée en boîte de nuit mais ça
fait quand même plaisir non et pourtant
tout n'est pas si simple pour les
entreprises qui rouvre le secteur de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration doit
faire face à un problème de taille le
manque de personnel sur les 650 mille
salariés des cent sept mille
établissements français cent mille
aurait décidé de quitter la profession
selon une étude menée par plusieurs
syndicats
un sixième de la profession quand même
face aux fermetures beaucoup ont
simplement décidé de se reconvertir de
changer de voir pour des métiers avec
moins de contraintes notamment pour ce
qui est des horaires et on ne parle pas
des saisonniers que le gouvernement
avait conseillé d'embauché pour les
placer en chômage partiel et qui seront
sans doute moins nombreux qu'il y a un
an cet été n'était d'ailleurs qui
inquiète aussi beaucoup entre les stocks
faramineux de certains magasins qui vont
avoir du mal à être écoulée la peur de
ne pas voir revenir les touristes en
nombre suffisant le manque de
rentabilité passe au maintien de
certaines mesures sanitaires comme les
jauges dans les restaurants ou les
magasins et bien sûr la fin progressive
des aides massives que l'état a mis en
place sans parler des dettes accumulées
pour tenir bon
il va falloir rembourser les femmes au
pge les prêts garantis par l'état